This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It's sometimes hard to know what stories we should tell when we're in the middle of a crisis. Some people need a story that helps them escape. Others need a story that directly confronts our anxiety. What I love about the episode we have for you today is that it's really both, and it also happens to be one of the most beautiful stories this show has ever produced.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。当我们身处危机之中时，有时很难知道我们应该讲述什么样的故事。有些人需要一个能帮助他们逃避现实的故事，而另一些人则需要一个能直面我们焦虑的故事。我喜欢今天这期节目的原因在于，它两者兼具，而且它恰好是本节目制作过的最美丽的故事之一。
A few years ago, we toured the West Coast with the rest of radiotopia, performing live stories on stage two sold out crowns. For our part of the show, 99% invisible collaborated with John Moellum and the Brink Players, which featured members of the Decembrists and black prairie. It was the story of Jeannie Chance, a woman whose voice held a shaken city together in a time of crisis. Even though the story of an earthquake in Alaska in 1964 has nothing directly to do with what many of us are going through now, it feels so urgent and important that we all listen to this together. After it was performed live a handful of times, John Mwellem continued researching and writing about feels so urgent and important that we all listen to this together.
几年前，我们与“无线电乌托邦”（Radiotopia）的其他成员一起在西海岸巡演，在舞台上为两场门票售罄的观众现场讲述故事。作为我们节目的一部分，《99%隐形》与约翰·莫勒姆（John Moe）及“布林克剧团”（Brink Players）合作，其中包含了“十二月党人”（The Decemberists）和“黑草原”（Black Prairie）乐队的成员。这是一个关于珍妮·钱斯（Jeanie Chance）的故事，一位在危机时刻用声音将一座动荡的城市凝聚在一起的女性。尽管1964年阿拉斯加地震的故事与我们许多人现在所经历的事情没有直接联系，但它让我们大家一起聆听这个故事显得如此紧迫和重要。在现场表演了几次之后，约翰·莫勒姆继续研究并撰写关于……（此处重复）
After it was performed live a handful of times, John Muellum continued researching and writing about Genius Chants and it eventually became a book that is out today as I report this and it is brilliant and beautiful. So, this week we're going to play the original live story song that we performed on stage, plus a brand new interview that I did with John last week. I hope you love it as much as I do. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It was the middle of the night. On March 27th, 1964, earlier that evening, the second biggest earthquake ever measured
在现场表演了几次之后，约翰·莫勒姆继续研究并撰写关于珍妮·钱斯的故事，它最终变成了一本书，在我报道此事的今天已经出版，它既精彩又美丽。所以，本周我们将播放我们在舞台上表演的原始现场故事，以及我上周对约翰进行的一次全新采访。我希望你们像我一样喜欢它。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。那是深夜。1964年3月27日，那天傍晚早些时候，有史以来测量到的第二大地震，
at the time, and insane 9.2 had mangled Anchorage, Alaska. 115 people died. Houses turned literally upside down or skitted into the sea. There was no light or power in the city, and for a long time, virtually no communication with the outside world. But there was radio. Are we on the air? Yes. We're ready to go again. It was a station in Anchorage running on backup generators and a cracked transmitter. The station in Fairbanks picked up that signal and repeated it. And a man in Juneau somehow picked up that Fairbanks station called a radio station in Seattle
当时，一场惊人的9.2级地震摧毁了阿拉斯加州的安克雷奇。115人死亡。房屋被彻底颠倒或滑入海中。城市里没有灯光或电力，很长一段时间里，与外界几乎没有任何通讯。但还有广播。我们播出了吗？是的。我们准备好再次开始了。这是一个依靠备用发电机和破损发射机运行的安克雷奇电台。费尔班克斯的电台接收到了那个信号并进行了转发。而朱诺的一名男子不知何故接收到了那个费尔班克斯电台的信号，并给西雅图的一家广播电台打了电话，
and let the broadcast play over the phone. The Boy Scout troop that went overnight to McQ Creek, Bill Noble would like to get a message if they are all right. Like that, a voice from Anchorage touched the lower 48, as sign the city was still there. And soon the degraded signal broadcast in Seattle was relayed and relayed again until eventually people across America then around the world heard the same woman's voice. We have word here that Mary Sweet is asked to contact her mother. Mother is at home. The president of that Anchorage radio station happened to be on a goodwill tour of Japan,
让广播通过电话播放出来。那个去麦克奎溪（McQ Creek）过夜的童子军小队，比尔·诺布尔（Bill Noble）想传个口信，看看他们是否平安。就这样，来自安克雷奇的声音触动了美国本土48州，标志着这座城市依然存在。很快，在西雅图广播的降质信号被一次又一次地中继，直到最终全美乃至全世界的人们都听到了同一个女人的声音。我们这里收到消息，玛丽·斯威特（Mary Sweet）被要求联系她的母亲。母亲在家。那家安克雷奇广播电台的总裁当时恰好在日本进行友好访问，
and when he turned on a radio in Tokyo, he couldn't believe it. It was the voice of his own news girl back home. The woman's name was Jeanie Chance. and the brink of players have her story. 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc
当他在东京打开收音机时，他简直不敢相信。那是他家乡电台女新闻播音员的声音。这个女人的名字叫珍妮·钱斯。而布林克剧团讲述了她的故事。1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc
1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ In 1964, Anchorage was the fastest growing city in America. A generation earlier, it had been a frontier town without a single concrete building. Now, it had a hundred thousand people.
1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc 1 tbc dc ʻ‿ʻ（此处省略重复字符）1964年，安克雷奇是美国发展最快的城市。一代人之前，它还是一个连一栋混凝土建筑都没有的边境小镇。现在，它拥有十万人口。
But it was mostly military build-up and oil speculation. The city felt like a bubble that could pop. Alaska had only been a state for five years and is one man, but it... You had the feeling that everything is temporary. We weren't all going to leave, but you know, we might. And that insecurity made every new construction feel monumental. It was a bit more proof to people that their city was real.
但它主要是军事建设和石油投机带来的繁荣。这座城市感觉就像一个随时可能破灭的泡沫。阿拉斯加成为州才五年，是一个人，但它……你有一种一切都是暂时的感觉。我们并不是都要离开，但你知道，我们可能会走。那种不安全感让每一项新建筑都显得意义非凡。这对人们来说是证明他们城市真实存在的又一点证据。
Like the brand new JC Penny Building Downtown, this was one of the first big chain retailers to build in Alaska, and it was huge. And nothing said sophisticated civilization rising out of the wilderness, like a five-story department store full of lingerie and blenders. There were the beginnings of genuine culture in Anchorage too, like the city's all-volunteer symphony conducted by a moonlighting bulldozer operator. In the Anchorage Little Theater, a community troupe run by a cosmopolitan guy in a turtle neck named Frank Brink.
比如市中心那栋崭新的杰西潘尼（JC Penney）大楼，这是第一批在阿拉斯加建造的大型连锁零售商之一，而且规模宏大。没有什么比一家摆满内衣和搅拌机的五层百货商店更能代表从荒野中崛起的精致文明了。安克雷奇也开始有了真正的文化，比如由一名兼职推土机操作员指挥的城市全志愿交响乐团。还有安克雷奇小剧院，一个由一位名叫弗兰克·布林克（Frank Brink）的、穿着高领毛衣的国际化人士经营的社区剧团。
Brink found roles for everyone in his place, housewives, judges, air force officers, and he worked his actors hard. He just staged his own three-hour epic of a laskin' history called Cry of the Wild Ram. I know it sounds a little bit like waiting for Guthman, but they were good. Meanwhile covering all this life in the city were two daily newspapers and five local radio stations. One of them, K-E-N-I, pride it itself on being. The biggest radio network in the biggest state in the union. And one of K-E-N-I's biggest on-air personalities was a woman woman named Jeannie Chance.
布林克在他的剧目中为每个人都找到了角色：家庭主妇、法官、空军军官，他让他的演员们努力工作。他刚刚上演了他自己创作的关于阿拉斯加历史的三小时史诗剧《野公羊的呼喊》（Cry of the Wild Ram）。我知道这听起来有点像《等待戈多》，但他们演得很好。与此同时，报道城市所有这些生活的是两份日报和五家当地广播电台。其中一家，KENI，以成为“最大州里最大的广播网”而自豪。而KENI最著名的广播名人之一是一位名叫珍妮·钱斯的女性。
Jeannie was 37. She'd grown up poor in Bonham, Texas, then come to Alaska with her husband a few years earlier looking for opportunity. They only sort of found it at first. He sold used cars and she watched their three kids at home. But Jeannie loved radio. So she started working construction every morning in exchange
珍妮37岁。她在德克萨斯州的邦纳姆（Bonham）贫困长大，几年前和丈夫来到阿拉斯加寻找机会。起初他们只是勉强找到了机会。他卖二手车，她在家里照顾三个孩子。但珍妮热爱广播。所以她开始每天早上做建筑工作以换取
for childcare, then go to work all afternoon at one of the local radio stations. Back then, women were usually made to cover cooking or fashion, but at KENI, Jeannie turned herself into a gutsy roving reporter driving all over Alaska with a mobile broadcasting unit in her car. She flew with smoke jumpers, covered Arctic warfare exercises, reported from inuit villages and crab boats. Her voice was part of the city, people trusted her, respected her in Anchorage, and in a way women journalists weren't always respected in 1964.
托儿服务，然后整个下午去当地的一家广播电台工作。那时，女性通常被要求报道烹饪或时尚，但在KENI，珍妮把自己变成了一名勇敢的流动记者，开着车，带着移动广播设备跑遍阿拉斯加。她和跳伞消防员一起飞行，报道北极战争演习，从因纽特村庄和捕蟹船上进行报道。她的声音是这座城市的一部分，人们信任她，在安克雷奇尊重她，这在1964年女性记者并不总是受到尊重的时代，是一种特别的认可。
Later, a New York paper celebrated her as... An Alaskan housewife and mother of three children who does a man-sized job with a radio microphone. LAUGHTER A late in the afternoon of March 27th, Jeannie was driving her 13-year-old son to a bookstore downtown. It was good Friday, and lots of people had already gone home from work for the Easter weekend.
后来，一家纽约报纸称赞她是……“一位阿拉斯加家庭主妇和三个孩子的母亲，用广播麦克风做着男人做的工作。”（笑声）3月27日傍晚，珍妮正开车带着她13岁的儿子去市中心的一家书店。那天是耶稣受难日，许多人已经下班回家准备复活节周末了。
A banner across fourth avenue advertised that weekends opening it Frank brings theatre. They were doing the Thornton Wilder play, our town. Curtain was going to go up at 8 o'clock, but at 536. She's the first one to be able to get her car out of the car. She's the first one to get her car out of the car. She's the first one to get her car out of the car. She's the first one to get her car out of the car. She's the first one to get her car out of the car. She's the first one to get her car out of the car.
第四大道上的一条横幅广告宣传着周末弗兰克·布林克剧院的开幕。他们正在排演桑顿·怀尔德（Thornton Wilder）的戏剧《我们的小镇》（Our Town）。大幕本应在8点拉开，但在5点36分……（此处重复）
She's the first one to get her car out of the car. She's the first one to get her car out of the car. She's the first one to get her car out of the car. She's the first one to get her car out of the car. She's the first one to get her car out of the car. She's the first one to get her car out of the car. She's the first one to get her car out of the car. She's the first one to get her car out of the car.
（此处重复）
She's the first one to get her car out of the car. She's the first one to get her car out of the car. She's the first one to get her car out of the car. She's the first one to get her car out of the car. She's the first one to get her car out of the car. She's the first one to get her car out of the car. She's the first one to get her car out of the car. of parked cars and the gas station slammed together and separated and slammed again. She watched them fold in and out and thought it's like a grotesque accordion. Later one man would say it felt like the earth was whipping the city around like a dog shaking an animal he's killed. Buildings listed off their foundations. The huge ground waves moved through the asphalt like the roads were liquid.
（此处重复）……停放的汽车和加油站猛烈地撞在一起，分开，又再次撞在一起。她看着它们折叠进出，心想：这就像一个怪诞的手风琴。后来有人说，感觉就像大地在像狗摇晃猎物一样摇晃着这座城市。建筑物从地基上滑落。巨大的地面波浪穿过沥青路面，仿佛道路变成了液体。
At the JC Penny Building of School Kids stuck in the elevator, watched a book, suddenly levitate off the elevator floor and hang weightless in mid-air in front of it. For split second, Miss Likky wasn't a orbit, and that's when he knew the elevator was falling. Quake went on like this for almost five full minutes. Then stopped. And the instant it did, Jeannie threw her car in gear. ["The
在杰西潘尼大楼，被困在电梯里的学生们看着一本书突然从电梯地板上悬浮起来，在他们面前失重地悬在半空中。那一瞬间，电梯仿佛进入了轨道，就在那时他知道电梯正在坠落。地震就这样持续了近五分钟。然后停止了。就在停止的那一刻，珍妮挂上了档。（“节奏布鲁斯”音乐）
R&B"] She was a reporter after all, and still not realizing how severe the situation was she raised to the police station to get a quick story for the evening broadcast. Inside all the filing cabinets were thrown over. Sealing plaster heaped on the floor. Then a second-chilled hit. And Jeanie's son, who'd gone off, came running around the corner shouting,
毕竟她是一名记者，在还没意识到情况有多严重的情况下，她冲向警察局，想为晚间广播获取一条简短的新闻。里面所有的文件柜都被掀翻了。天花板的灰泥堆在地上。接着第二次余震袭来。珍妮的儿子跑过拐角大喊：
Come quick, the pennies just fallin' down! An enormous concrete panel that shorn away from the JC pennies exterior in fallen. Now the entire building was sagging and running over, Ginny watched a second panel, lurch loose, and dropped with a roar. The scene was brutal. Ginny stepped around part of a body in the snow, a person split in two by the falling debris. A Chevy station wagon was flattened, but you could hear a woman still alive inside calling to the crowd trying to dig her out.
“快来，杰西潘尼大楼要塌了！”一块巨大的混凝土板从杰西潘尼大楼的外墙脱落并坠落。现在整栋建筑都在下沉和倾斜，珍妮看着第二块板子摇摇欲坠，伴随着轰鸣声掉落。现场惨不忍睹。珍妮绕过雪地里的一具残骸，那是一个被坠落碎片劈成两半的人。一辆雪佛兰旅行车被压扁了，但你还能听到里面有个女人还活着，在向试图挖掘她的人群呼救。
Then, Jeannie rounded a corner, saw the whole impossible panorama. One entire side, the fourth avenue, had just dropped. For two blocks, everything was 12 or 15 feet lower in a ravine that had opened under half the street. The crazy part was buildings were still intact down there. Cars were still perfectly parked next to their meters. Men looked up from outside a bar, a dozen feet underground like stunned miners,
然后，珍妮转过一个拐角，看到了整个不可思议的全景。第四大道的一整侧刚刚塌陷。在两个街区的范围内，一切都下降了12到15英尺，掉进了一个在街道一半下方裂开的沟壑中。最疯狂的是，那下面的建筑物竟然还完好无损。汽车依然完美地停在停车计时器旁边。男人们从酒吧外面抬头看，像惊呆的矿工一样站在地下十几英尺处，
and still hanging there over the street like a cruel caption over this surreal wreckage was the theater banner that read our town the Quake had knocked Genie's radio station off the air but now the static on the transistor radio she was carrying suddenly gave way to music. It meant Kei and I was back. An engineer started talking and Jeannie grabbed the radio unit in her car and cut in. Go ahead Jeannie. She was surprised later when people told her she sounded calm. It has become obvious that the earthquake that struck Anchorage less than an hour ago
而那条横幅依然悬在街道上方，像是在这超现实的残骸上写着一句残酷的标题——《我们的小镇》。地震震断了珍妮的广播电台，但现在她随身携带的晶体管收音机里的静电突然变成了音乐。这意味着KENI恢复了。一位工程师开始说话，珍妮抓起车里的广播设备切入进去。“继续，珍妮。”后来人们告诉她，她的声音听起来很冷静，这让她很惊讶。“显而易见，不到一小时前袭击安克雷奇的地震
is a major one. We urge each and every one of you to seek shelter, check your emergency supplies, and plan to keep your homes closed as much as possible so that you can retain the heat. Check your neighbors, see if they have transistor radios. If they don't, possibly they could move in with you
是一场大地震。我们敦促你们每一个人寻找避难所，检查应急物资，并计划尽可能多地关闭房屋，以便保持室内温度。检查你的邻居，看看他们是否有晶体管收音机。如果没有，他们可能可以搬到你那里，
and share one for the night. It seems like it's going to be a long, cold night for Anchorage, so prepare to batten down the hatches and stay tuned to K-E-N-I. ["Pomp and Circumstance"] I think of what it means when we say a person feels shaken. In Anchorage, this wasn't a metaphor. The whole city had been thrown.
今晚共用一台。对于安克雷奇来说，这似乎将是一个漫长而寒冷的夜晚，所以准备好加固门窗，并继续收听KENI。”（“威风堂堂进行曲”）我想，当我们说一个人感到“动摇”（shaken）时，这意味着什么。在安克雷奇，这不仅仅是一个比喻。整座城市都被抛掷了。
There'd only been about an hour between the quake and nightfall, and with the power out, and snow falling through a thick fog in the dark. There was no way for everyone to tell just how badly their world had been jumbled. The feeling of vulnerability of total dislocation was hard to describe. This one guy put it, You don't know if anyone else is alive. Maybe you were the last man. So it was comforting to hear another voice start talking to you. Especially Jeannie Chancen's voice.
地震发生到天黑之间只有大约一个小时，电力中断，黑暗中浓雾夹杂着雪花飘落。人们无法得知他们的世界被搅乱到了什么程度。那种脆弱感和彻底的错位感很难描述。正如一个人所说：“你不知道还有没有其他人活着。也许你是最后一个幸存者。”所以听到另一个声音开始和你说话是令人欣慰的。尤其是珍妮·钱斯的声音。
After making that first announcement on the air, Jeannie drove back to the police station. Authorities realized that with the radio unit in her car, she was the only voice they're able to address the entire city. So they told her to keep talking. Soon they got her broadcasting from inside the building and rounded phone calls to her as the lions reopened. It was up to Jeannie to decide what information to relay to the public.
在广播中做出第一次公告后，珍妮开车回到警察局。当局意识到，凭借她车里的广播设备，她是唯一能向全城喊话的声音。所以他们告诉她继续说。很快，他们让她在建筑物内进行广播，并在线路恢复后将电话转接给她。由珍妮决定向公众传达什么信息。
At first, it was mostly just her. One K-Yin and I employee remembers that the newscaster had been on the air when the Quake struck. A hot shot, they just tired away from a big station in Los Angeles. Had been so weaked out that the second that shaking stopped, he'd walked out of the building without a word.
起初，基本上只有她一个人。一位KENI员工记得，地震发生时正在播音的新闻主播，一个刚从洛杉矶大电台挖来的“大人物”，被吓坏了，震动停止的那一秒，他一言不发地走出了大楼。
He resurfaced a couple weeks later, calling from back in California to officially quit. And Jeannie was shaken too. A week later, she'd break down out of nowhere and weep all night, but now. I kept trying to forget the unforgettable scenes I had witnessed. Thousands of terrified people were huddled in their unheated shelters, waiting for words of reassurance and instruction. So she started doing her job, talking to people on the radio. Before long, the rest of her colleagues and other stations in town were back working the airwaves too, but still often felt like Jeannie was the one at the center of things, directing things.
几周后他才露面，从加州打来电话正式辞职。珍妮也受到了震动。一周后，她会毫无征兆地崩溃，整夜哭泣，但现在，“我一直在努力忘记我所目睹的那些令人难忘的场景。”成千上万惊恐的人们蜷缩在没有暖气的避难所里，等待着安慰和指示的话语。于是她开始做她的工作，在广播里和人们交谈。不久之后，她的其他同事和城里的其他电台也恢复了工作，但人们仍然觉得珍妮是处于中心位置、指挥一切的那个人。
The turbine site needs diesel fuel, she'd say, or here's where electricians should report. And then she started reading the personal messages, pouring in too. Mr and Mrs Dick Fisher are still here at Police Headquarters waiting for any word of their children. We have a message from Northwest Airlines saying that the crew cannot locate Sturdis Beverly Johns. So many people were desperate to locate or reassure each other. Howard Forbes would like it to be known that he will be at Mike Whitmore's. And Jeannie was helping those people shout across the fractured city.
“涡轮机现场需要柴油燃料，”她说，“或者电工应该到这里报到。”然后她开始阅读源源不断涌入的个人信息。“迪克·费舍尔（Dick Fisher）夫妇仍在警察总部，等待关于他们孩子的任何消息。”“我们收到西北航空公司的消息，称机组人员无法找到斯特迪斯·贝弗利·约翰斯（Sturdis Beverly Johns）。”太多人急于寻找或安慰彼此。“霍华德·福布斯（Howard Forbes）想让大家知道他会在迈克·惠特莫尔（Mike Whitmore）那里。”珍妮正在帮助这些人在这座破碎的城市中互相呼喊。
A message to Kenneth Sadler. Mrs. Sadler is fine. A message to Walter Hart. Lee Hart is fine. And meanwhile, Ham Radio operators were relaying those messages to families in the lower 48. And when reporters around the country finally got through to Anchorage, it was often Jeannie still sitting in front of her radio microphone who took their calls.
“给肯尼斯·萨德勒（Kenneth Sadler）的消息：萨德勒夫人很好。”“给沃尔特·哈特（Walter Hart）的消息：李·哈特（Lee Hart）很好。”与此同时，业余无线电操作员正在将这些信息转发给美国本土48州的家庭。当全国各地的记者最终联系上安克雷奇时，往往是珍妮依然坐在她的广播麦克风前接听他们的电话。
No, she assured that the city wasn't swallowed in flames. And no, it wasn't under martial law. She talked to Omaha, New York, London. One interview she did was rebroadcast in more than a hundred other places the same day. broadcast in more than a hundred other places the same day. Friday night it becomes Saturday morning right then. Then Saturday afternoon, Saturday night. For the first 30 hours I talked constantly. And after two hours sleep she was right back on the air. It's probably worth stopping for a second to say this out loud. Earthquakes are f***ed up. But I mean, in an existential way too. Imagine how dreamlike it must have been, watching reality suddenly buckle around you,
不，她保证城市没有被火焰吞没。不，它没有处于戒严状态。她与奥马哈、纽约、伦敦通话。她做的一次采访当天就在其他一百多个地方进行了转播。（此处重复）周五晚上变成了周六早上，然后是周六下午，周六晚上。在最初的30个小时里，我一直在不停地说话。在睡了两个小时后，她又回到了广播中。也许值得停下来大声说出这一点。地震真是太糟糕了。但我的意思是，从存在主义的角度来看也是如此。想象一下，看着现实突然在你周围崩塌，那一定像梦一样，
watching your city of infallible right angles, and it was enough to change a person's worldview. More than 50 years later, a former mayor of Anchorage told me, even now I can look at this solid ground out the window and know that it's not permanent. It can change any time. It just moves. Everything moves. moves. I understand that in 1964, plate tectonics was still just a theory. Kind of a radical one. It was hard for people to accept that the continents we stand on are actually in motion.
看着你那充满完美直角的城市，这足以改变一个人的世界观。50多年后，一位安克雷奇前市长告诉我，即使现在，我看着窗外这坚实的地面，也知道它不是永恒的。它随时可能改变。它只是在移动。一切都在移动。我明白，在1964年，板块构造论还只是一个理论。一种相当激进的理论。人们很难接受我们所站立的大陆实际上是在运动的。
They were just sliding around randomly, on violently colliding plates of rock, and that nothing is stable, that everything runs on pure chance. That's what this story is about really, chance. Maybe that's obvious, it's even the woman's last name. But the question is, how are are we supposed to live on the surface of such unbearable randomness. And what can we grab hold of? It's fixed. Well, when I hear the old recordings of Genie on the radio that weekend and all the other voices working to,
它们只是在随机滑动，在剧烈碰撞的岩石板块上，没有什么东西是稳定的，一切都纯粹靠运气。这才是这个故事真正的主题：偶然（Chance）。也许这很明显，这甚至是那个女人的姓氏。但问题是，我们该如何生活在如此难以忍受的随机性表面上？我们能抓住什么？它是固定的吗？嗯，当我听到那个周末珍妮在广播里的旧录音，以及所有其他也在努力工作的人的声音时，
a picture of them is solid objects, like wires crossing the city of Anchorage and the state of Alaska further out, crossing each other to like a net kind of alternate further out, crossing each other too, like a net, kind of alternate human infrastructure, snapping into place where the built environment gave way. The a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a The new has accommodations for two people at Pile 9 on the shore to highway. The YMCA is in battery and neither for the athletes. And the battery life boy shots sharp. If anybody has a sharp sword, they're a bit rough.
我脑海中浮现出他们像坚实的物体，像穿过安克雷奇市和阿拉斯加州更远地区的电线，像网一样交织在一起，一种替代性的人类基础设施，在建筑环境崩塌的地方连接起来。（此处省略重复字符）……如果你有锋利的剑，它们有点粗糙。
You can go to the Japanese Airlines before you see final days. I'm very interesting person. I think you can tell it's about some of the damage out at your name. This is one of this time right now to evaluate what is happening here. Three, two, one. Last stop. Red Cross, last stop. The cross that you're developing.
你可以去日本航空公司……我是一个非常有趣的人。我想你可以看出这与你那里的部分损坏有关。现在是评估这里正在发生什么的时候了。三，二，一。最后一站。红十字会，最后一站。你正在开发的十字路口。
You're not in the railroad. You would like more as to contact Elton, Georgia. You're naming a second to the Long Island. Three, four, three, four, three. The English, the French, the French, the French, the French, the French. The area is a small area of the country. The
你不在铁路线上。你想要更多……联系埃尔顿，乔治亚州。你正在命名……（此处重复）
area is a small area of the area. At the Milti, your relatives and angry are all right.
（此处重复）……在米尔蒂，你的亲戚和安格里都很好。
Side building. Okay, the road is too dark to open. The
侧面建筑。好的，路太黑了，无法打开。
work is going hard. The road is too dark to walk through my bed. I work as a woman, I'm so silly, silly. It's going to be fine. In Cardovan, at the northern hotel, the message says your family has been contacted and everything is okay. I've been so involved trying to assist down here in the coordination of the message service at the Chivaldi-Saint-Float Headquarters
工作很辛苦。路太黑了，无法走过我的床。我作为一个女人工作，我太傻了，太傻了。一切都会好起来的。在科尔多瓦的北方酒店，消息说你的家人已经被联系上了，一切都好。我一直忙于协助这里的消息服务协调工作，在奇瓦尔迪-圣弗洛特（Chivaldi-Saint-Float）总部，
that I really hadn't stopped the thing. I'm worried and concerned my parents must be. I understand that KFAR and Fairbank is monitoring us and is relaying messages to the South 48. I wonder if the person in KFAR would take down a message from me and get the word to my family in Bonham, Texas that the chance family is all right. The chance family is all right. All five of us are safe.
我真的没停下来思考。我担心我的父母一定很着急。我知道费尔班克斯的KFAR电台正在监测我们，并将信息转发给南部48州。我想知道KFAR的人是否能记下我的口信，并告诉我在德克萨斯州邦纳姆的家人，钱斯一家很好。钱斯一家很好。我们五个人都平安。
None of us received a scratch. We have another message for you. ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ‿ʻ Late on Saturday, the day after the quake, Jeannie read a list of the missing and dead on the air. No one told her to do it, but there didn't seem to be anyone to ask for permission either. The next day was Easter Sunday. Ministers talked about death and resurrection, a staff of the Anchorage Daily Times picked up all the pieces of movable type, thrown all over their printing room, managed to put out a newspaper. To JC Penny executives declared, We will build again, bigger, and better than before. And eventually the little theater resumed its production of our town, too. One of the actors told me that after the quake, whenever a restaurant and anchorage reopened
我们中没有人受一点伤。我们还有另一个给你的消息。（此处省略重复字符）周六晚些时候，地震发生后的第二天，珍妮在广播中读了一份失踪和死亡名单。没有人告诉她这样做，但似乎也没有人可以去征求许可。第二天是复活节周日。牧师们谈论着死亡与复活，《安克雷奇每日时报》的工作人员捡起了散落在印刷室各处的活字，设法印出了一份报纸。杰西潘尼的高管们宣布：“我们将重建，比以前更大、更好。”最终，小剧院也恢复了《我们的小镇》的演出。一位演员告诉我，地震后，每当安克雷奇的一家餐馆重新开业，
or a church held a mass, there was never an empty seat, he said. Everyone wanted to be with someone else. And there was something especially poetic about the sold-out crowd at the theater that first night. Because that kind of togetherness is basically what Thornton Wilders plays about. It's a play about daily life in a small town, the deaths and marriages, tragedies, births, and how, under all that flux, there's stability to every community over time. In Anchorage, a city that worried it was temporary, realized it was temporary, at least all its buildings and houses and roads. But it was discovering there was something permanent about itself too.
或者教堂举行弥撒，座位从来没有空过，他说。每个人都想和别人在一起。而剧院第一晚门票售罄的观众有一种特别的诗意。因为那种团结正是桑顿·怀尔德的戏剧所讲述的内容。这是一部关于小镇日常生活的戏剧，死亡与婚姻、悲剧、诞生，以及在所有这些变迁之下，每个社区随着时间的推移都有一种稳定性。在安克雷奇，这座担心自己是暂时的城市，意识到它确实是暂时的，至少它所有的建筑物、房屋和道路都是如此。但它发现自己也有某种永恒的东西。
All night at the theater, the character of the stage manager talked to the audience directly, narrating the story of the play, kind of like I've been doing tonight. Now, when the curtain rose on the final act, he came out for his monologue and told them. Now there are some things we all know, but we don't take them out and look at them very often. We all know that something is eternal, and it ate houses, and it ate names, and it ate earth, and eight names, and eight earth, and eight even stars.
在剧院的整晚，舞台经理的角色直接与观众交谈，讲述剧中的故事，就像我今晚所做的那样。现在，当最后一幕大幕拉开时，他走出来进行独白，告诉他们：“现在，有些事情我们都知道，但我们不常拿出来看。我们都知道有些东西是永恒的，它吞噬了房屋，吞噬了名字，吞噬了大地，吞噬了名字，吞噬了大地，甚至吞噬了星星。”
Everybody knows that their bones are something is eternal, and that something has to do with human beings. All the greatest people ever lived in Antonia's that for 5,000 years, and yet you'd be surprised how people are always losing hold of it. In the end, Jeanne Chant stayed on duty with K and I for 59 hours that weekend. When things finally calmed down, she sat down to write a letter to her parents in Texas. They'd written to her right after the quake, pleading with Jeanne to send her three kids to live with them, while that battered city up in Alaska figured out what's next. Think of the kid's safety, they said.
“每个人都知道他们的骨头……有些东西是永恒的，而那东西与人类有关。所有最伟大的人都生活在安东尼娅（Antonia）……五千年来，但你会惊讶于人们总是如何失去对它的把握。”最终，珍妮·钱斯那个周末在KENI值班了59个小时。当事情终于平静下来时，她坐下来给德克萨斯州的父母写了一封信。地震后他们立刻写信给她，恳求珍妮把三个孩子送到他们那里住，而阿拉斯加那座受损的城市正在想办法应对接下来的事情。“想想孩子的安全，”他们说。
And part of Jeanie thought it was a good idea, but then she had another more convincing thought. We must be together. As long as we're together, we are confident of the future. She explained to her parents. That good Friday night, I knew we had survived miraculously. And for this reason, there must be a purpose to our lives. Apparently the children must sense this too, for they have remained calm.
珍妮的一部分想法觉得这是个好主意，但随后她有了另一个更有说服力的想法。“我们必须在一起。只要我们在一起，我们就对未来充满信心。”她向父母解释道。那个耶稣受难日的晚上，我知道我们奇迹般地幸存了下来。因此，我们的生命一定有某种目的。显然孩子们也一定感觉到了这一点，因为他们一直保持冷静。
They have been fully aware of the emergency, but have not feared. We are proud that they are such dependable, responsible youngsters. I would not undermine their confidence in the future. In themselves, We are proud that they are such dependable, responsible youngsters. I would not undermine their confidence in the future, in themselves, by sending them away for their safety. What is safety anyway? How can you predict where or when tragedy will occur? You can only learn to live with it and make the best of it when it happens. These children are not afraid.
“他们完全意识到紧急情况，但并不害怕。我们为他们是如此可靠、负责任的年轻人而感到自豪。我不会通过把他们送走来削弱他们对未来、对自己的信心。我们为他们是如此可靠、负责任的年轻人而感到自豪。我不会通过把他们送走来削弱他们对未来、对自己的信心。什么是安全？你怎么能预测悲剧会在哪里或何时发生？你只能学着去接受它，并在它发生时尽力而为。这些孩子不害怕。”
Their father and I are not afraid. Please, don't you fear for us. What is safety anyway? A genie seemed to be conceding that there is only randomness, only chance. And if everything beyond us is chance, maybe the only force we have to survive a world like that is connection. By then, it must have seemed so obvious to her.
“他们的父亲和我也不害怕。请不要为我们担心。”什么是安全？珍妮似乎在承认只有随机性，只有偶然。如果超越我们的一切都是偶然，也许我们在这样的世界中生存的唯一力量就是联系。到那时，这对她来说一定显而易见。
To good idea, it'll hold on to each other. Thank you. John Moelleum, the break players, Jenny Conley Dries-Oce, on accordion of piano, Nate Creary on bass, John Moelleum on drums, Chris Fonda on guitar, and John Newfield also on guitar. And that is Miss Avery Troubleman, as Chini Channets. Thank you. This story was recorded live at the More Theatre in Seattle in 2017. More about Jeannie Chance and John's new book, This Is Chants. After this. John Mwellem expanded the story you just heard into a beautiful and important new book called
“好主意，我们要互相扶持。”谢谢。约翰·莫勒姆，布林克剧团，珍妮·康利（Jenny Conley）演奏手风琴和钢琴，内特·克里里（Nate Creary）演奏贝斯，约翰·莫勒姆演奏鼓，克里斯·方达（Chris Fonda）演奏吉他，约翰·纽菲尔德（John Newfield）也演奏吉他。那位是米斯·艾弗里·特鲁布曼（Miss Avery Troubleman），饰演珍妮·钱斯。谢谢。这个故事于2017年在西雅图的莫尔剧院（Moore Theatre）现场录制。关于珍妮·钱斯和约翰的新书《这就是钱斯》（This Is Chance）的更多信息，稍后回来。约翰·莫勒姆将你刚才听到的故事扩展成了一本美丽而重要的新书，名为
This Is Chants. And I had a conversation with them several days ago, right about the time the reality of the pandemic was just hitting a lot of people. And I started off by asking him how he first learned about genie chance. Basically I had first learned about a tsunami in Crescent City, California. This was like 20 years ago I had learned about this tsunami in 1964 that wiped out this town of Crescent City, California. And I just started to learn about that in a roundabout way at a diner in Crescent City one day when I saw these historical photos about it. And there's
《这就是钱斯》。几天前，就在疫情的现实刚刚冲击到许多人时，我和他进行了一次谈话。我首先问他是如何第一次了解到珍妮·钱斯的。基本上，我最初是了解到加州克雷森特城（Crescent City）的海啸。那是大约20年前，我了解到1964年的那场海啸摧毁了加州克雷森特城。我有一天在克雷森特城的一家餐馆里，通过历史照片以一种迂回的方式开始了解这一点。而且有
just some really interesting things about this story, about sort of like the resilience of a community that stuck with me. And it wasn't until like many, many years later, until about 2013 or 2014 that I thought to like Google it basically and it was like oh yeah like what caused the tsunami you know and what caused the tsunami was this massive quake in Alaska and it was a pretty short amount of time between starting to get curious about the earthquake and stumbling on you you know, Jeannie. Basically because Jeannie had produced a lot of material about the Quake afterwards, and you know, just interviewed a lot of people and compiled these almost like oral history documents, and even co-authored a scientific paper with the USGS about it.
关于这个故事的一些非常有趣的事情，关于社区的韧性，这让我印象深刻。直到很多很多年后，直到2013年或2014年，我才想到去谷歌搜索它，当时我就想：“哦，是的，是什么导致了海啸？”你知道，导致海啸的是阿拉斯加那场大地震，从开始对地震产生好奇到偶然发现你，你知道，珍妮，时间很短。基本上是因为珍妮在地震后制作了大量材料，你知道，采访了很多人，汇编了这些几乎像口述历史的文件，甚至与美国地质调查局（USGS）合著了一篇关于它的科学论文。
So her name was out there, but even then it was still just like a few more years. Even though I had reached out to her daughter, which became just the most important connection that made this book possible, it still took me a few years even to get up to Jan, his daughter's house, and look at all the material that Jeannie had left behind, which was just, you know, like 30 something boxes of of everything from her life. And at that point it was just like, oh my god, like
所以她的名字就在那里，但即便如此，还是又过了几年。尽管我联系了她的女儿，这成为了使这本书成为可能的最重要的联系，但我还是花了几年时间才去到珍妮女儿的家，查看了珍妮留下的所有材料，那简直是，你知道，大约30多箱她生活中的一切。在那一刻，感觉就像，“天哪，”
there's there was just such an opportunity to reconstruct these three days in Anchorage. I mean the book really just tells the story of these three days. And yeah, I just, I couldn't, I didn't feel like I could see that opportunity and not, and not do it because it was really like almost like an hour and everything. Like who else is going to be in this basement ever again, right? So the first incarnation was the live story song that you made for 99% visible. And so, did you always have a book in mind? How did it expand? How did that work in your mind? Yeah, well, the great thing about doing that project with you guys was that it gave me the time and sort of the motivation
“这简直是一个重建安克雷奇那三天经历的绝佳机会。”我的意思是，这本书确实讲述了这三天的故事。是的，我只是，我觉得我看到了那个机会，不能不去做，因为它真的就像是一个小时，一切都在那里。我的意思是，还有谁会再进这个地下室，对吧？所以第一个化身是你们为《99%隐形》制作的现场故事歌曲。那么，你一直有写书的想法吗？它是如何扩展的？这在你的脑海中是如何运作的？是的，和你们一起做那个项目的伟大之处在于，它给了我时间和某种动力
to just see if it was a book. I definitely had that in mind. I was hoping that that's what it could become. But it's such a weird process of just coupling together of these material, you know, documents and our from archives, various places. So, you know, but pretty, you know, definitely by the time we were done with that project and we were starting to do the performances. It was very clear to me that this was like kind of just the beginning. And yeah, it was just this process of discovering like all these other characters and all these nuances to the story and just learning more about Anchorage at the time and just this fuller, you know, sense, almost like a more
去看看它是否能成为一本书。我确实有这个想法。我希望它能变成那样。但这是一个非常奇怪的过程，将这些材料，你知道，文件和来自档案馆的各种地方的东西结合在一起。所以，你知道，但很明显，当我们完成那个项目并开始进行表演时，我很清楚这只是一个开始。是的，这只是一个发现所有这些其他角色和故事中所有细微差别的过程，只是更多地了解当时的安克雷奇，以及这种更全面、你知道，几乎更
empathetic sense too of what was happening there, both after the Quake, but also just what it was like to be living in Alaska in 1964. And then also just finding more and more material, both Genie's documents and then this huge trove of documents from these sociologists that came to Anchorage to interview everyone about the Quake and sort of study the community's response. You know, they interviewed almost 500 people and I had access to all of their transcripts. Were these meticulous, like, blow-by-blow accounts of, you know, tell me everything that happened. So, yeah, they're just, as I gathered more of that, I saw all of these other threads just spooling out of, you know, what I had already known.
同理心的感觉，关于那里正在发生什么，不仅是在地震之后，还有1964年生活在阿拉斯加是什么感觉。然后还发现了越来越多的材料，既有珍妮的文件，还有来自那些来到安克雷奇采访每个人关于地震并研究社区反应的社会学家的巨大文档库。你知道，他们采访了近500人，我查阅了他们所有的笔录。这些都是细致的、逐条的记录，你知道，“告诉我发生的一切。”所以，是的，当我收集到更多这些信息时，我看到了所有这些其他线索从我已知的内容中延伸出来。
And so specifically that group from Ohio that went to study it, the story of the Anchorage earthquake, it's really interesting to be talking about it right now when people are figuring out ways to deal with a crisis as it unfolds and after it happens. How did the research and writing of this story change the way you view of how people act in a crisis? Yeah, I mean, I think it's a very bizarre experience that I've spent almost six or seven years with all of this in my head to various degrees. And then now, at the same time, the book is being materializing as a real object in the world to just have the world be kind of collapsing around it.
所以特别是那个去研究它的俄亥俄州小组，安克雷奇地震的故事，现在谈论它真的很有趣，因为人们正在寻找应对危机的方法，无论是在危机展开时还是在危机发生后。研究和撰写这个故事改变了你对人们在危机中如何行动的看法吗？是的，我的意思是，我觉得这是一种非常离奇的经历，我花了近六七年的时间，在不同程度上把所有这些都装在脑子里。然后现在，与此同时，这本书正在作为一个真实的物体在世界上实现，而世界却在它周围崩溃。
But yeah, I don't, I wish I had some very pithy moral that I could draw from all this and just dispensed everyone. And in some sense, I think it's there, but I'm still struggling to articulate. But basically, these social scientists, they came to Anchorage thinking that they were funded by the military. They were thinking that they were just here to watch a community fall apart and tell, you know, as a sort of simulation of nuclear war, so we could figure out how to control that kind of chaos. And what they found was just like really what we were talking about in that, in the piece is just this cooperation and this altruism that just surged up from the community,
但是是的，我不知道，我希望我能从中得出一些非常精辟的道德结论，并分发给每个人。在某种意义上，我认为它就在那里，但我仍在努力表达。但基本上，这些社会科学家来到安克雷奇时，认为他们是由军方资助的。他们认为他们只是来观察一个社区的崩溃，你知道，作为一种核战争的模拟，这样我们就能弄清楚如何控制那种混乱。而他们发现的，正如我们在那篇文章中谈到的，只是这种从社区中涌现出来的合作和利他主义，
this impulse that everyone had to just solve problems and cooperate and just get stuff done. And I think we're definitely, we're feeling that same thing now. You know, I think it's just way more opaque as to, you know, what we're supposed to do with that energy. And it's, you know, it's something I've been turning it just over and over in my mind. And I think it's just the problem is just that the danger is just not right in front of us the way that it is with an earthquake. And I think it sort of scrambles your brain in that way. But I do think that, you know, I have this piece
这种每个人都有的解决问题、合作并完成任务的冲动。我认为我们现在肯定有同样的感觉。你知道，我认为对于我们应该如何利用这种能量，情况要模糊得多。而且，你知道，这是我一直在脑海中反复思考的事情。我认为问题仅仅在于危险并不像地震那样直接摆在我们面前。我认为这在某种程度上扰乱了你的大脑。但我确实认为，你知道，我有这篇文章……
in the near times that's sort of an excerpt of the book, where I'm just making the point that I do think we need to kind of understand, you know, these things were being told to do, like wash our hands and keep our distance and all of these things that seem like sacrifices or retreats and just try to understand them as as a way to channel that same energy that these are things we're doing together. This is a project that we're doing together. Even if we're, you know, I'm I'm saying would be new or revelatory to any of the sociologists that study this because that, that field of sociology has, you know, gone on in the, in all the years since the quake and it's, you know, really on firm ground
在近期，这算是书中的一个摘录，我只是想表达一个观点，即我认为我们需要去理解，你知道，那些被告知要做的事情，比如洗手、保持距离，以及所有这些看起来像是牺牲或退让的事情，并试着将它们理解为一种引导同样能量的方式，即这些是我们共同在做的事情。这是一个我们共同参与的项目。即使我们，你知道，我是在说，对于任何研究这个领域的社会学家来说，这都是新的或具有启发性的，因为社会学领域在地震后的这些年里一直在发展，而且它确实有坚实的基础。
that this is just a phenomenon. This is just the way humanity deals with disasters and this collaborative, you know, improvise productive way. But yeah, it's strange to just think about the similarities but also the differences. Yeah. I mean, that essential truth is really contradictory to what we tend to tell stories about in fiction. You know, we tend to tell stories about the pressure cooker of disaster leading to society breaking down.
这只是一个现象。这就是人类处理灾难的方式，这种协作的、即兴的、富有成效的方式。但确实，思考这些相似之处以及差异是很奇怪的。我的意思是，这种基本事实与我们在小说中讲述的故事往往是矛盾的。你知道，我们倾向于讲述灾难的压力锅导致社会崩溃的故事。
You have you thought about why there's that impulse to tell those stories when the reality is not that way and maybe more interesting because of it? Yeah, I mean, I think it's not just in fiction. I think we tell that story about real life, too, right? Sometimes to our detriment, like it's dangerous because if you are in the aftermath of a disaster and you're looking at everyone around you as Barberic or potentially their whole drive is to harm you and steal what you have, you're going to address the world very differently than if you walk in with an assumption that people can be trusted
你有没有想过，为什么当现实并非如此，甚至可能因此而更有趣时，人们会有讲述这些故事的冲动？是的，我的意思是，我认为这不仅仅是在小说中。我认为我们在现实生活中也讲述那个故事，对吧？有时甚至是有害的，因为这很危险，如果你处于灾难的余波中，你把周围的每个人都看作是野蛮人，或者认为他们的全部动力就是伤害你并偷走你的东西，那么你处理世界的方式将与你带着人们可以被信任的假设进入世界时截然不同。
and that were allies. But yeah, I think in some ways, there might just be something on a gut level that we're afraid of, and so we assume it to be true. But it's really hard to let go of those myths. I mean, even one thing that I just found so entertaining was when you read enough of these case studies or even just press accounts of disasters. And it was true in Alaska too, is that, you know, well, we pulled together because we were Alaskans, right? You had so many Alaskans saying that. And you had the sociologists who just had to kind of
并且我们是盟友。但是，是的，我认为在某些方面，可能在直觉层面上我们确实感到害怕，所以我们假设它是真的。但要放下这些神话真的很难。我的意思是，甚至有一件事让我觉得非常有趣，那就是当你阅读足够多的这些案例研究，甚至是灾难的新闻报道时。在阿拉斯加也是如此，你知道，嗯，我们团结在一起是因为我们是阿拉斯加人，对吧？你有那么多阿拉斯加人这样说。而那些社会学家不得不以某种方式
push back and say, you know, everyone did, like even the fact that they found themselves exceptional turned out to be unexceptional because, you know, after Katrina was New Orleans, you know, we're just being New Orleans or you know New Yorkers after New Orleans, well we're New Yorkers and just no one can get their head around the fact that you know what's true for everyone else, everyone else is gonna collapse and you know turn into heatens but we're the one place that has our f*** together you know. So I found that very amusing.
反驳并说，你知道，每个人都这样，甚至他们发现自己与众不同这一事实也被证明是平庸的，因为，你知道，卡特里娜飓风之后是新奥尔良，你知道，我们只是在做新奥尔良人，或者你知道新奥尔良之后的纽约人，嗯，我们是纽约人，只是没有人能理解这样一个事实，你知道，对其他人来说是真的，其他人都会崩溃，你知道，变成异教徒，但我们是唯一一个把事情处理得井井有条的地方，你知道。所以我发现这非常有趣。
I don't know, I guess it's just really hard to register. And even me, I'm not trying to, I mean, even now, I know these things. I've written about them. I'm out here saying them in public, but I have to kind of reassure myself that they're true. And I also think that, frankly, I'm talking to you from Washington State, right? Where everything feels just
我不知道，我想这真的很难察觉。即使是我，我不是想，我的意思是，即使现在，我知道这些事情。我已经写过关于它们的内容。我在这里公开说出来，但我必须以某种方式向自己保证它们是真的。而且我也认为，坦率地说，我正在华盛顿州和你通话，对吧？那里的一切感觉只是
probably a little bit more intense. Yeah. But I think I've also just made the decision for myself that I'm just gonna act like they're true and I'll be proven wrong. And I would prefer to live in a world where I see, where I see that the possibility of that cooperation and the possibility of that goodness, rather than just always being unguarded for the opposite. Yeah. One of the things that we get
可能稍微强烈一点。是的。但我认为我也为自己做出了决定，我只是要表现得好像它们是真的，如果我错了，我会得到证明。我宁愿生活在一个我能看到合作的可能性和善良可能性的世界里，而不是总是对相反的情况毫无防备。是的。我们得到的一件事
the privilege of in the audio piece that we performed on stage versus the book is you get to hear some of these voices at the end. And I remember doing it on stage and nearly crying every time that moment happens. And what was it like hearing those for the first time when you were going through archives? I was unreal. I mean, especially certain moments. There's a... I mean, especially in certain moments, you know, there's a... I mean, I had so many written documents, right? I had so many interviews and letters and you get this sense of real life, but it's almost kept at a distance from you. You know, there's that buffer.
在我们在舞台上表演的音频片段中，与书相比，特权在于你可以在最后听到其中一些声音。我记得在舞台上表演时，每次那一刻发生时我都差点哭出来。当你翻阅档案时，第一次听到这些声音是什么感觉？那是不真实的。我的意思是，特别是在某些时刻。有一个……我的意思是，特别是在某些时刻，你知道，有一个……我的意思是，我有很多书面文件，对吧？我有很多采访和信件，你有一种真实生活的感觉，但它几乎与你保持距离。你知道，有那个缓冲。
And then when you hear the voices, it shatters that, right? I mean, not completely, right? They're still, you know, the tapes are fuzzy and they've kind of, some of the men, especially, seem to have that kind of old-timey cadence, you know? But yeah, there's something about it, there's just something about hearing people speak and hearing the confusion in their voices, but also hearing the energy they're putting into fighting back that confusion, that I just find so moving and so noble. And on top of that, I had all these recordings of just ordinary radio broadcasts and anchorage
然后当你听到这些声音时，它打破了这一点，对吧？我的意思是，不完全是，对吧？它们仍然，你知道，磁带很模糊，而且它们有点，特别是其中一些男人，似乎有一种老式的节奏，你知道？但是，是的，关于它有一些东西，仅仅是听到人们说话，听到他们声音中的困惑，但也听到他们为对抗那种困惑而投入的能量，我发现这非常感人，非常高尚。最重要的是，我还有所有那些只是普通广播和安克雷奇的录音
or genie kind of making audio diaries of things. And yeah, you can just sort of feel yourself being sucked through time in a way. In this story, we are witness to like a little sliver of genie's life. She went on to do lots of interesting things afterward. Can you tell a little bit about what her life was like after the quake? Yeah, she, I mean, it was a real kind of catapult for her. You know, the first thing that happened was she got super depressed and stressed out, I think, just covering the months and months of like, you know, boring recovery work and infighting and all the stuff that followed this sort of
或者吉妮在制作音频日记。是的，你可以感觉到自己以某种方式被吸入了时间。在这个故事中，我们见证了吉妮生活的一小部分。她后来做了很多有趣的事情。你能稍微讲讲她地震后的生活是什么样的吗？是的，她，我的意思是，这对她来说确实是一个弹射器。你知道，发生的第一件事是她变得非常沮丧和压力很大，我想，仅仅是报道了几个月的枯燥的恢复工作和内斗，以及随之而来的所有事情，这种
period of great cooperation. As soon as the government agencies got involved in figuring out all the technical stuff. But yeah, she actually left her job at the station shortly after because she, they wouldn't give her a raise because she was a woman, essentially, and she felt kind of indignant about that, right fully. And she went off on her own. She became kind of a woman about town, like a publicity consultant, just kind of hustling and doing all kinds of freelance work.
合作的伟大时期。一旦政府机构介入并弄清楚所有技术问题。但是，是的，她实际上在不久之后就离开了电台的工作，因为她，他们不会给她加薪，因为她基本上是个女人，她对此感到非常愤慨，这是理所当然的。她独自一人离开了。她成了一个社交名媛，像个公关顾问，只是在忙碌，做各种自由职业。
And that eventually led to a people started asking her to run for office. And so she became a state legislator in Alaska in, I believe, 1971, and was there for many years. And just did a whole bunch of stuff there with the kind of same, you know, even a greater spirit of just, you know, who gives a damn? I'm going to do the right thing, kind of attitude, which, you know, didn't necessarily make her a favorite among some of her, especially the kind of older male colleagues who looked at their positions and legislators as a sort of like a treat that they were entitled to after long careers in business.
这最终导致人们开始要求她竞选公职。所以她在1971年左右成为了阿拉斯加的州议员，并在那里待了很多年。并在那里做了很多事情，带着同样，你知道，甚至更伟大的精神，你知道，谁在乎呢？我要做正确的事情，这种态度，这，你知道，并不一定让她在一些同事中受欢迎，特别是那些年长的男性同事，他们把自己的职位和立法者视为一种在长期商业生涯后有权获得的奖励。
But the other thing that happened to was that she was in very bad marriage. Her husband at the same time that he could be very loving and you know, they were very happy family He was also an alcoholic and he was abusive toward her very very violently and you know She never really addressed it, but it seems clear both reading the stuff that you're out and talking to people that around her Was that the from the earthquake on there was really this process of her just kind of trusting in her own strength I guess would be a way to put it or just kind of feeling more confident about making decisions in her life and that led to her leaving her husband and eventually remarrying to. So yeah, I really had no idea about any of that until much later in the process.
但另一件事是，她的婚姻非常糟糕。她的丈夫在可以非常爱她的时候，你知道，他们是非常幸福的家庭，但他也是个酒鬼，他对她非常非常暴力，你知道，她从未真正解决过这个问题，但无论是阅读你写的东西还是与她周围的人交谈，似乎很清楚，从地震开始，她确实经历了一个过程，只是以某种方式相信自己的力量，我想这是一种表达方式，或者只是对在生活中做出决定感到更有信心，这导致她离开了丈夫，并最终再婚。所以，是的，直到过程的后期，我真的对所有这些一无所知。
But yeah, it turned out she was, I guess it makes sense that if you find a sort of remarkable person doing extraordinary things on one weekend that you'll probably find the rest of their life pretty fascinating too. Yeah. Some of her relatives came down to see it when we performed in Seattle. What was that like? Oh, that was amazing. I couldn't completely, yes, so her daughter Jan and her husband were there and then two of Jan's children. And I believe like a niece or cousin or somebody. And they came from both from Alaska and then there's some folks that were living in
但是，是的，事实证明她是，我想如果在一个周末发现一个非凡的人在做非凡的事情，你可能会发现他们生活的其余部分也相当迷人，这很有道理。是的。当我们在西雅图表演时，她的一些亲戚来看了。那是什么感觉？哦，那太棒了。我无法完全，是的，所以她的女儿简和她的丈夫在那里，然后是简的两个孩子。我相信还有个侄女或表亲什么的。他们来自阿拉斯加，然后还有一些人住在
Texas. And yeah, there's a whole kind of half-row of them at the performance which was just so wonderful because I really never had this experience, you know, working on anything before where so many people that I called Just told me outright like I've been waiting for someone to call me because they're writing about this, you know, either, you know, often just about the quake, but, but several people about Jeannie herself, you know, like, oh yeah, I've been waiting all my life for someone to call me and ask me about Jeannie Chance. And I think that her, her family, you know,
德克萨斯州。是的，他们在表演现场坐了半排，这真是太棒了，因为我以前在做任何事情时真的没有这种经历，你知道，我称之为的那么多人直接告诉我，就像我一直在等有人给我打电话，因为他们在写这个，你知道，要么，你知道，通常只是关于地震，但是，但有几个人是关于吉妮本人的，你知道，就像，哦，是的，我一生都在等有人给我打电话问我关于吉妮·钱斯的事。我认为她的家人，你知道，
her daughter definitely felt that too, you know, her, her, I think her daughter just knew what an extraordinary person her mom was. And that's why she was holding on to all our things, all these years, and it didn't just toss them. And the other cool thing too was, I'd be in their basement just looking through all this stuff. Like, I would stay with them and go up for a few days at a time. And I remember one night being just up really late, just like going through box after box. And Jan's daughter, so Jeannie's granddaughter, who was living in an apartment next to their house at the time, came home, you know, from being out with her husband at a bar or something. And we got to chatting and I was like, you
她的女儿肯定也感觉到了，你知道，她的，我想她的女儿只是知道她的妈妈是一个多么非凡的人。这就是为什么她这些年来一直保留着我们所有的东西，而没有把它们扔掉。另一件很酷的事情是，我会待在他们的地下室里翻看所有这些东西。就像，我会和他们住在一起，一次上去几天。我记得有一天晚上我熬得很晚，只是翻看一盒又一盒。简的女儿，也就是吉妮的孙女，当时住在他们房子隔壁的公寓里，你知道，和她丈夫从酒吧回来什么的。我们开始聊天，我说，你
know, at one point I said, so, you know, how, what did you really know about your grandma like? Because she was pretty young when Jeannie died. She said, you know, to be honest, I didn't really know much about her until you started, you know, poking around, you know, and we started talking about it again. So yeah, it's, I don't know, to be honest, I didn't really know much about her. And so you started poking around. You know, we started talking about it again. So, yeah, I don't know. There's just something, maybe it's like a middle-aged thing, like a middle-aged on 40s, but there's just like something really potent and moving about just kind of seeing the way people's memories can kind of catapult through time.
知道，有一次我说，那么，你知道，你对你奶奶真正了解多少？因为吉妮去世时她还很小。她说，你知道，老实说，在你开始，你知道，四处打听之前，我真的不太了解她，你知道，我们又开始谈论它了。所以，是的，这是，我不知道，老实说，我真的不太了解她。直到你开始四处打听。你知道，我们又开始谈论它了。所以，是的，我不知道。有一些东西，也许这就像中年人的事情，就像40多岁的中年人，但看到人们的记忆以某种方式穿越时间，确实有一些非常有力且感人的东西。
And the impacts that they have. And yeah, I don't, and to also just recognize that it's, you know, yes, genius like fascinating and did amazing stuff, but like how many other lives out there? Could you just, if you found this way into, you know, would deliver that, just that same kind of rush, you know, that recognition of just like another human. This is Chance, the shaking of an all-American city, a voice that held it together by John Muallem is out today.
以及它们产生的影响。而且，是的，我没有，也要认识到，你知道，是的，吉妮很迷人，做了了不起的事情，但是，还有多少其他生命？如果你找到了进入的方式，你知道，会带来那种，那种同样的冲动，你知道，那种对另一个人的认可。这是《钱斯》，一个全美城市的震动，约翰·穆勒姆的声音，今天发布。
Get it, seriously, get it, for yourself, for a friend, for the sake of the world, get it today. 99% Invisible was recorded at the More Theater in Seattle on the Radio Topia Live West Coast tour. We were directed by Lynn Finkle, post-production mix by Sean Riel and Sheree Fusef. Words by John Moellum and Music by the Brink Players, Jenny Conley Dresos, John Newfeld, Nate Query,
去买它，认真地，去买它，为你自己，为朋友，为了世界，今天就去买它。99% Invisible是在西雅图的More剧院录制的，这是Radio Topia西海岸巡演的一部分。我们由Lynn Finkle导演，后期制作由Sean Riel和Sheree Fusef混音。文字由John Moellum创作，音乐由Brink Players、Jenny Conley Dresos、John Newfeld、Nate Query创作，
John Moenn, and Chris Funk. Jeannie Chance was played by Avery Troubleman. The rest of the group is Katie Mingle, Kurt Colesette, Delaney Hall, Emmett Fitzgerald, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Leigh, Chris Baroubae, Sophia Klatsker, and me Rowan Morris. We are a project of 91.7 KALW and San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which is now distributed in multiple locations
John Moenn和Chris Funk。吉妮·钱斯由Avery Troubleman饰演。团队的其他成员是Katie Mingle、Kurt Colesette、Delaney Hall、Emmett Fitzgerald、Joe Rosenberg、Vivian Leigh、Chris Baroubae、Sophia Klatsker，以及我Rowan Morris。我们是91.7 KALW和旧金山的一个项目，在Radio Row制作，现在在多个地点分发
in beautiful East Bay, California. We are a proud member of Radio Topia from PRXF, the fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. But we have a link to purchase the book.
在美丽的加利福尼亚州东湾。我们是来自PRXF的Radio Topia的骄傲成员，这是一个由播客中最具创新性的节目组成的激烈独立的集体。在radiotopia.fm上找到它们。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并加入关于该节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@Roman Mars，关注节目@99PI org。我们在Instagram和Reddit上也有账号。但我们有一个购买这本书的链接。
This is Chance. You must get it. You must, must get it. That link is at 99PI dot org. Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是《钱斯》。你必须买它。你必须，必须买它。该链接在99PI点org。来自PRX的Radio Tapio。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。